unable to be
bounded it's so
simple you can't box this in any
way you can't bound
it you can't put a concept or idea on
it no groupings or
categorizations
none that's the addictive
tendency of the
contraction always grasping and clinging
to making
boxes
as its defense
mechanism from the
boundlessness that it always already
is so the contracted energy uses boxes
and Concepts and
Bounds to Shield itself to try to repel
itself away
from the boundlessness that it already
is and it's
hopeless so it's better to just
fearlessly identify as this
boundlessness as this
everythingness as this
nothingness as this wholeness
everything is
you this
boundlessness and it's unconditional
love and it's unconditionally
free no
conditions no boxes no bounds no
Concepts and finally the lasting
contentment well-being
satisfaction Joy
humor
peace all the good things that are so
deeply sought and
desired but they cannot be found from
boxes and
Bounds the game of
positioning self and others and
separation and lack and need and
validation meaning and purpose
becoming
self-actualization
attainments
goals I will be happy
when
mm boundlessness here now this simply
this
no added
Concepts no added
[Music]
ideas just the freedom that is already
there right now it's already there right
now it's already Unbound Freedom there
there right
now that unconditional love right there
right
now and everywhere forever
ER